hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so
let's get into it guys today we're gonna
go through as usual amc jamie press
action
not a good day again guys um
let's analyze what is happening let's
see what can happen next we're gonna go
through the hourly press action and the
daily time frame as well we're gonna see
what are the longer term uh scenarios
that we have uh and we're of course
gonna analyze what just happened today
we are right now four hours before
market close we have fed us um
fed chair powell that is talking in 30
minutes 40 minutes from here so let's
see what's gonna happen uh markets
happened quite good today and it's
getting dumped now so let's analyze the
situation guys so we're gonna start with
amc
so let me uh remind you guys what i was
saying in my yesterday's video we are
looking for some bullish signs all right
this is what we want to see
and we had a good combination of bullish
signals but we were missing a very
important indicator which was the volume
so here
uh
this is the situation guys i'm using
right now here the forest time frame
and i was telling you that
in a move down we are looking first for
consolidation that is happening here and
after consideration we can have uh
either a reversal or a continuation
after the consideration in the same
direction which is here on the downside
so
uh we are trying to guess if this
consolidation is going to give us a
reversal or not and uh the reason why uh
here we had some good signs was once
again guys bam again to make the bam so
one macd
here one rsi here
and
as you can see it was on the hourly time
frame i showed you that yesterday but we
also have this bullish divergence on the
forest and frame
as you can see here bam bam the macd is
making higher lows the price action is
making lower lows which is a sign of
exhaustion of the current move which is
on the downside so it's a good situation
good environment for a reversal
especially when this is happening on low
volume then we had this breakout on
again it's very small volume this is the
reason why this breakout here
this is the reason why the breakout
didn't give us a reversal it could have
happened it didn't happen
we then
found some support when we pulled back
here on this trend line which is once
again after being resistance becoming a
support and today uh we also had the 17
level that was a support because it has
been touched once twice almost three
times and today uh we often we opened
the day uh very well we were uh we went
close to the
18 area we went even slightly above that
level and then we got again rejected
strongly on low volume so the only good
news here is once again to see those
strong moves down happening on low
volume why is it the good news because
it means that um it's not a price that
everybody agrees upon it's a price that
has been printed by only a few investors
uh which doesn't mean that we can't go
lower but it just means that this kind
of moves is easier to
reverse whenever buyers will get in for
now buyers are not here definitely and
this is
something that we could see in this
breakout on low volume again because
usually when you have a breakout you
have an increase in volume because
everybody is jumping in because this is
needed for this breakout to happen uh
here it was happening on low volume so
once again this signal was not reliable
and as you can see it got rejected so
right now
i think we're heading for the 16.3 level
which is the next support why 16.3
because
it's the best i have it's first as you
can see the breakout level
so each time you have a breakout even if
it was one month ago or whatever it's a
level where
a lot of buyers
would like would have liked to be in
i mean it's a level that a lot of buyers
would be happy to uh buy to be in the
move that followed this breakout now we
are correcting so they remember oh at
16.3 i remember that there was a
resistance and that uh
this
that after this resistance was broken we
had a massive move up so they remember
the lowest level before the massive move
up so here it's 16.3 it's also and it's
not a surprise the level that we saw
here once twice
so basically
um
this is to me the next support so right
now we can wonder once again as you guys
saw there are many many fake outs so
those breakouts are not very reliable
because they don't happen on high
volumes so
they are attacked either by bulls when
they are downside breakouts or by bears
when their upside breakouts so that's
not easy to uh find good signals in this
kind of console in this kind of
situation
but here we have a breakout below the 17
level once again is it a good breakout
not really because it happened on low
volume first uh and there was not any
consolidation close to the uh breakout
before uh close to the uh support before
breakout so
to me it's not a very strong signal
maybe it's just going to be bought back
and we're going to come back at higher
levels but right now to me the story is
that we need to go a little bit lower
bears are still in control uh to then
find some support and finally hopefully
get this reversal done
so
this is my view guys um next support
16.3 bez are still in control on the
short term even if we are in a nice area
for reversal for now the bullish signals
we got didn't give us any uh reaction
from bulls so bulls saw that and they
didn't get in so they're waiting for
something else
what are they waiting for guys they're
waiting for some bullish action price
action on the global market uh so maybe
today uh today's speech is gonna impact
the price action positively i don't know
i personally both as you guys know at
337.4
uh i'm having right now uh a stop loss
so once again i didn't manage to take
profit today i'm having my profit taking
just here we went close i didn't take
profit it's fine i'm having my stop-loss
at
339.5 so i just got stopped right now or
maybe one minute ago but it's not a big
position so it's fine and i'm still i'm
getting stopped but i'm still in profits
so i'm fine with that uh because i
bought lower
um
and this is what i'm gonna be monitoring
so for now i'm not turning bearish on
the global market i'm still neutral as
as as i told you guys yesterday uh we
have the very very similar press action
on amc on dme on triple q so i'm gonna
keep monitoring the three and i'm gonna
try to see where this might be heading
uh and what i trust
is my analysis on triple q because once
again this is a civilized market with
that is not manipulate not manipulated i
mean it's impossible to manipulate such
a
big market as triple q which is the
nasdaq hundred etf so you basically
can't manipulate the whole economy of a
country right especially the united
states uh so it's easier to i mean the
signals are more reliable on triple two
and here my view on triple q
is that um
as long as we are above 338 we are
looking good but once again look at that
guys you remember
you remember what i told you
a good breakout is a breakout that
happens after a consolidation
on low volume but on indices volume is a
little bit
i mean different in terms of
interpretation
but it's still true whenever you have a
consolidation that is happening and then
a breakout so consolidation is
uh when the price action is trading in a
tight range
testing many times in the recent past a
support or resistance then
this is a situation for good and
reliable breakouts and
unfortunately yes this is a little bit
what we're having here uh as you can see
this consolidation is very very um tight
and clean i mean
you know i'm staying on the daily
timeframe but you can see guys the range
we are trading in
for the past
eight days
and
the support for me is at 338 even if we
had some access below that level
it's the level that is for me important
because uh bam bam bam
because as usual guys i have some good
reactions in the past around this levels
so one two three they're not perfect
for
but they are good enough for me to make
this level a strong support and
especially i don't even need to have
perfect reactions in the you know past
like one month to month
because look at the very recent past
this is where
my i mean
supports are really clear so i keep 338
once again because this is on the daily
timeframe the right level to for me to
watch
but if i check
this on the shorter timeframe i could
allow some access to 336 all right
because this is where we went already
um
[Music]
and so basically
i don't want to see a close below this
level so
as i said we have some access to 336
um
but i still don't want to see a close
below 200 338 for now
this is neutral um everything can happen
we don't have a lot of information we
have an rsi around 50 we have a macd
that is you know close to zero slightly
negative let's be honest uh
i don't have any big volume either on
green days or red day to give me some
information so
um
i think the best thing i have here is
maybe this trend line
that has been broken here you can see
small volume increase
not even the volume increase happen here
so this trend line has been broken
without volume so forget what i said
um but it's still a breakout that
happened on low volume so now i think
we're
finding some support here so i really
want to believe in this um
in this reversal in this bullish
reversal that is starting here uh once
again
the macroeconomics are not good guys the
situation in the world is not good
um but we are coming from a very very
strong bull market so
you know just like for bearish moves
bullish moves take time to reverse so
for now investors are still full of cash
uh because a lot of investors made a lot
of money in this massive move up that we
had here
uh so they are okay losing some money
and they're still gonna you know uh come
back to the to the market and you know
buy
so for now the bullish sentiment is
still here technically speaking
um
but the fundamentals are not good guys
so once again like i said yesterday i'm
not sure what direction this market will
take
um but we need we need
this market to be bullish for amc dme to
squeeze all right uh a squeeze is very
unlikely to happen if we correct
so
i'm not giving you a lot of information
today because we are roughly at the same
levels on triple q as we were yesterday
when i did my video
so we're in the same situation we're
still waiting you can see the market is
in the wait and see mode probably
waiting for what paul is going to say
even if we know a little bit the
situation and we don't have big data
published today so
um
yeah i don't have much new information i
can tell you what i did today uh i
bought some model now i showed you that
trade already uh before
why did i go to moderna because i think
we're a nice
situation for reversal
because we have this wedge that has been
broken
with increasing volume as you can see
here
we are now
pulling back which is totally fine and
we are at the 61.8 percent retracement
so this level
is usually a level that is acting as
support you can see here it's supporting
very well the price action for the past
past three days
so i jumped in this trade i'm not using
a stop loss uh usually i use a stop loss
which allows me to increase my position
because i can take leverage
because i'm not going to keep the
position for long
for
a big amplitude of spot of price i mean
here i decided not to use a stop loss
because the stock is very undervalued to
me i showed you that yesterday or not a
few days ago guys the price earning
ratio of modernize at
five or 5.5 which is very very very low
uh the usual price earning ratio are
rather around 20 which would mean we
would mean that if modernity needs to be
at this uh same price on uh
yeah the same price earning ratio uh the
the stock price would need to be
multiplied by four which gives us a
price at around 600 so i'm not saying
modena should be trading at 600. every
stock has its own story the story of
modernize of course related to the kovid
and you know investors are just thinking
like all right the covet is behind us so
we don't need uh modern vaccines anymore
that's not true because they're working
on many different vaccines uh and the
covenant is not behind us i believe that
we're gonna need a vaccine
in in the long term and the technology
they built is a very new technology that
can be used in many many different ways
so for all these reasons i believe that
the price earning ratio of moderna is a
very good reason to buy and hold this um
the stock this is what i'm going to do
it's not a financial advice
it might very well go to 100 guys which
is a 30 move down all right so i'm
prepared for that and i'm just gonna buy
more if we go if we if we go close to
the 100 area because
basically the money they made three
years ago
um
is equivalent to a price at 100 so if
you look not at the profits at
everything they sold it's equivalent to
um a market cap of a price of a stock
which
which price would be 100 so i think that
it's capped at 100 basically this is
what i'm trying to say so i
really don't see madonna going below 100
and we have a nice support which is the
bottom of the force wave of this whole
move up here at 100 so i'm just gonna
split my orders between 150 i mean 48
and 100 so i'm gonna buy in three
trenches
and i'm happy to keep this position
so that's it for today guys i'm keeping
it short nothing much to add uh we can
have a look again at amc quickly what's
happening here
nothing much we broke out below 17 we
are now you know just waiting a bit to
see i think what's gonna happen in the
rest of the market
um
so let's see guys i'm pretty much
neutral here on the global market i'm
you know slightly having a bullish bias
because technicals are strong and we
have to me a situation that can um can
be nice for a reversal but once again if
i look at the macroeconomics and the
fundamentals i'm not feeling uh very
bullish
on just looking at that so let's see
technicals versus fundamentals who's
gonna win we're gonna find out soon guys
thank you very much for watching i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to show i
see you guys